welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on why we are in
fact not the good guys instead we are
the baddies and we need to be destroyed
for the safety of the multiverse my name
is jessica clemens jessica clemens
jessica clemens three syllables and i'm
here today with off-screen producer
brandon hello jessica of three syllables
it's so good to see you again i'm glad
you're back again it's so i'm so glad
we're we're doing a a double whammy a
double header if you will two weeks in a
row baby i know it's been good it's good
for me it's good for my skin uh it's
good for me for my skin and i know that
you only invite me back because i am
indeed a baddie you're the queen battery
that's the theme of today are we the
baddies are we the baddies are we the
baddies yeah that's exactly why you're
here because i know you love being a
villain and today's all about how the
mcu is the villain
we are okay
and after i took a sip of my capri sun
it's a villain drink what's our big
question for today well jessica dr
strange and the multiverse of madness is
just around the corner and it's been
confirmed that the illuminati are gonna
make their presence known in the mcu i
know we all saw the trailer and we're
like oh it's the illuminati the
illuminati
but now like in empire magazine they
even said illuminati in a caption and
that had to be approved by kevin feige
or he would have sent his sniper team to
take him out so we know that they're
going to show up in the mcu it's a fact
they're coming baby and apparently these
illuminati have some truth that they
need to let doctor strange in on could
that truth be some bad news for the mcu
it all leads us to this week's big
question is the earth 199
universe dangerous and needs to be
destroyed is it is that that's our earth
that's we are that's our earth right
this is earth one nine nine five nights
earth one nine nine nine
is the mcu that is the mc's yeah that's
all right that's our earth well
technically it could it could not be why
technically
we're a different earth i think if you
get into it i think we're a different
earth main marvel is earth 616 of course
yes and then there's all sorts of
different you know earth and i think
we're technically a separate one though
i guess in the realm of earth 199 999 he
above all would be
kevin feige right who exists in our
universe so i don't know exactly how
that works but
we'll hash all that out later okay
that's math for you the events of the
mcu aka earth 199 999 have been quite
dramatic over the last 14 years of
cinematic history
and now that the marvel's illuminati is
showing up it can mean that the mcu is
marked for deletion delete delete delete
the links they're going to delete the
mcu i'm calling it now baby
i think you have the illuminati coming i
think it's bad news for the mcu i think
they might want to take us out okay well
let's get into it okay so in the comics
the illuminati first formed after the
cree scroll war and consisted of mr
fantastic iron man professor x doctor
strange black bolt and namor yes uh it
was iron man who brought them together
when he realized they all had
information that had they had worked
together could have prevented this whole
thing from happening so they got
together and they're like yeah we're all
we're all pretty smart fellas we're we
run different areas of you know marvel
comics and different groups of people
we're kind of like rulers of our little
areas so if we all work together we can
stop some of these bad things from
happening um so over the years the
lineup of the illuminati has shifted
like members have come and gone but
their goal has remained the same
protecting their universe as best they
can
in more recent times this is often meant
preventing incursions from other
universes and an incursion is where two
universes collide
with earth being the main point of
impact so the illuminati is always like
oh my god this other earth is gonna
smash into us we gotta go blow it up
first
which is kind of dark but you know their
point is if we gotta kill one universe
to save two from being deleted i guess
that's okay okay the fact that the
illuminati is showing up in multiverse
of madness at a time in the mcu where
the concept of the multiverse is so
vital and so important might not bode
well for our beloved earth 199
so let's go through some of the evidence
to see what could possibly be marking
our universe for deletion i say our
universe because we love them so much
right it's not our our universe but it's
their universe you know what i mean you
get it yeah it's not our universe but
also this list is so long of reasons why
they should be
it'd be easier to make a list of why we
deserve to stay in the game oh oh that's
a good that would be a short episode
yeah and the
the reason is we don't the end goodbye
you're gone let's begin with the giant
elephant doctor in the room that being
doctor strange okay these are some of
the things he's done just lately that
has really uh
caused them to look at our our universe
a little poorly okay he manipulated
memories across the multiverse you know
spider-man no way home and in that film
he's pulling people in and out of their
timelines he's messing with their
timelines okay he fixed all he let all
these villains get fixed and sent them
back granted that was peter parker he
wanted to do that but he let it happen
he's the the vice sorcerer of supreme
he's not the source of supreme he's
second in command he's doing all this
crazy garbage the butterfly effect is
just already broken everything's
everything's chaos now every like strand
that was once woven has now been ripped
apart after they come back and they're
like i'm not a villain anymore right
before they die right before they die
they're like you know what no i'm out of
this we were talking about this around
the office where he pulls in these
villains just as they're about to die
right
and the spider-man he pulls in andrew
garfield and toby mcguire is not at the
same moment it's much later in their
lives so they fix all these villains and
presumably the villains go back to that
moment right before they died and they
don't die they live different lives
they're different people now but i i
assume that spider-man go back towards
oh they're still saying
right and so like stick for it's just
like tobey mcguire right he goes back to
his universe a universe where you don't
have doc ock and green goblin is harry
still alive now does he show back up and
harry's alive does he show up and otto
octavius and norman osborne have been
like working together for 20 years and
ozcorp is this huge mega corporation
that runs the world i don't want to know
the chaos they went back to and they
were all smiling at the end it's
probably horrible what they went back to
yeah it's like back to the future you go
back in biff's in charge now and he's
running the world third time's a charm
it's dangerous they're looking for their
version of doctor strange to try to
resettle
they probably did honestly they're
probably looking for their doctor
strange that doesn't
it's not doctor strength you gotta do
some of this garbage he's still uh he's
still working he's still a surgeon like
they're gonna go to the surgeon and be
like don't make don't become a magician
he's gonna be like what i love the idea
of like totem mcguire like busting it to
like a surgery room and there's dr
steven strange just doing surgery he's
like break that man's hand
we gotta break his hands take his
fingers we gotta get him
you gotta learn some magic mother
i'm not getting any better i miss the
part where that's my problem
yeah fix this [ __ ] go break his hands
okay so that's some [ __ ] that dr strange
has done he also if you remember way
back in the first doctor strange movie
he made a bargain with dormammu dormamma
who runs the dark dimensions yes like
maybe our earth was supposed to get
swallowed away and it didn't because he
made this bargain with the ruler of the
dark dimension where all the evil magic
comes from he made a deal with him he
made a deal with him and it's going to
come back it's going to come back like
you may go back if you make a bargain
that's a long that's a long-term
contract that is literally the
definition to bargain like i the fact
that okay doctor strange alone is the
reason why this entire world needs to be
reset but keep going keep going off
about why he's a mistake so let's
remember back to the actions of the snap
in the blip right that's all because of
doctor strange he convinces tony who's
kind of handling his business he's like
no there's only one way to do this and
it's me allowing thanos to get the time
stone and do the snap okay he could have
kept the time stone hidden forever he
could have died knowing where the time
stone was hidden but he allows thanos to
do all this so that he could do the snap
and then then undo the snap like that's
insane that doesn't happen in the comics
he doesn't get to finish his plan like
that
it's not okay i i realize this is me
this is me going through like all the
stages of like you go through it
but like
recognizing i was wrong
i'm not saying i'm i'm like we're naming
off the reasons of why doctor strange
would be a major point to why we deserve
to be reset but i'm not saying that
those things weren't valid you know you
know what i'm saying so like when he was
like i've seen all these outcomes you
dying right now is not one of those
outcomes in the first uh end game i
understand where he's coming from but
like the spider-man one he didn't have
to do no way home that's all him no one
told you to do that you could just
ignored him completely and been like
that's what happens dude a lot of people
come out and take their mask off like
purposefully like he didn't have to do
that but like
i guess the dormammu one he really had
no choice right you could say that i
guess but he still did he still did it
like he just asked everybody if it's
cool right and even with the snap in the
blip we're taking it at his word that he
viewed all these things and said this is
the only way to do it maybe there was a
way to stop thanos before the snap even
happens but then like you know tiamat
gets born and destroys the earth so he's
like no not that one or maybe there's
the one where they stop thanos the snap
never happens and like doctor strange
you know
breaks his leg and he's like i don't
want to do that that's going to hurt a
lot it's like
we're trusting that he did this and he
got our tony killed he got our natasha
killed just because we trust him with
this one way it's going to turn out yeah
he didn't have to come up with these
decisions on his own but he did so it
looks like he definitely needs a team of
people to bounce ideas off of and that
team would be the illuminati it needs a
boardroom i started this company you
know how much i sacrifice yeah i need to
think things for sure and so he i mean
those people would be the illuminati but
what if he just never knew about the
illuminati because wong's part of the
illuminati the entire time and wong has
been like you don't need to know about
it this has nothing to do with you until
you actually you don't end up messing
[ __ ] up well that'll be interesting if
we if it if it turns out that the mordo
we see in the trailers is the mordo from
the illuminati and they're like we can't
have doctor strange on the illuminati we
need mordo who's got a good head on his
shoulders honestly he's thinking through
some of these things honestly
i'm for that
i'm for that yeah the illuminati in the
comics dr strange does some crazy
crazy-ish and they i think they kick him
out at one point they're like you can't
be in the old one
you're out of control buddy oh my god
you're wilding out we can't we can't do
it because mordo was technically staying
aligned with his
he was like i can't work with the
sorcerer's supreme because she
betrayed us she was using power from the
dark dimensions the one thing she said
you couldn't do it
and he was following her the entire time
and did just that be like i
i blindly followed and i'm not going to
blindly follow no more right like i'm
going to stand for myself so i can see
him being a leader instead of dr strange
who literally falls for everything
so doctor strange he's like doing all
this stuff and all the stuff in
spiderman knowing home right he wasn't
even sorcerer supreme and he's still
getting away with like this nonsense and
we see in the trailer for multiverse of
madness it looks like our universe is
collapsing it's fading away so it's like
it's clear he's done a lot of damage and
i think you know the alumni is going to
show up and be like this this universe
has got to go it's a problem it's going
to damage all the other universes out
there it's going to destroy the
multiverse we got to get rid of this one
universe if not this one universe they
got to get rid of our doctor strange
he's a menace someone's gotta stop him
he's a menace okay so that's dr strange
jessica and we can't mention doctor
strange without talking about his love
christine paul
something else we've seen i don't mind
her i don't mind her either i got
nothing against her i have nothing let
the woman get married yes let her get a
nice stable man who's not running
literally portals in her hospital all
the time
literally he doesn't deserve christine
he does not deserve he does not deserve
and he's making her life a mess he's
doing nothing good for her what is he
bringing to the table other than death
but keep going sorry keep going keep
going yeah yeah i know something we've
seen in the trailer footage is a
christine palmer variant that appears to
be working with the illuminati or at
least in their facility and wearing like
a uniform that matches the aesthetic
basically she doesn't look like she's a
prisoner there it looks like she's doing
like work there now the what if series
which is established to be canon in the
mcu
it showed the importance of christine
palmer's death to the story of that
universe as doctor strange right it was
a nexus point in the episode the ancient
one calls it an absolute point uh but
series writer ac bradley later clarified
that it's a nexus point
and the confusion comes from the fact
that the loki series hadn't come out
when they were writing the what if
series cause you got to write animated
shows so much earlier so they didn't
have the term nexus point they called it
an absolute point but it's basically the
same thing it's it's kind of this like
important moment in time that in that
universe had to happen because otherwise
stephen strange doesn't learn his powers
right it's it's something very similar
to the story of the time machine where a
man builds a time machine to go back to
stop his his wife or his betrothed from
being killed but if she's never killed
then he never has the idea to build the
time machine so he can't go back so it
can't stop her from being killed every
time he goes back to try and stop it she
still dies in a new way we saw that
that's what basically happened in what
if right as we know the christine palmer
in the mcu is still alive is that a
problem clap if you think she should
suffer
should our christine have died and who
do we think this illuminati christine is
okay hear me out jessica
if our christine in the mcu if she
actually should have died that would
have given stephen
more grounding more emotional grounding
as a sorcerer instead like she's still
alive and he's kind of a jackass
sometimes and he's very full of himself
still and like yeah his hands were hurt
and he had to learn to overcome that or
to learn to overcome his own uh trauma
and disability but like his love is
still alive he doesn't even care about
her he's always just pushing her to the
side like is that the problem with with
the mcu is our christine didn't died and
so because of that we have a lackluster
uh stephen strange i could have done
better
gonna cry i get where you're coming from
i just kept assuming after that dr
strange would if that our christine's
gonna die soon we just haven't seen it
so he hasn't hit oh okay oh our universe
so i think she's still gonna die
we just haven't seen it maybe that's the
horrible person of me i think she's
gonna die we just haven't seen it yet do
you think that wedding we see do you
think that's a um a dream is it is it
something that stephen strange is
fantasizing is it real does she actually
get married does she maybe die at the
wedding because you die after the
wedding is it a red wedding what's gonna
happen jessica the the the the bad side
of jessica wants her to die at the
wedding the bad jessica wants her to get
killed at the wedding i would i would i
would freak out in the theater if i see
that scene i would lose my marbles if
she died at a wedding a red wedding
absolutely would love to death um but
maybe it is just a fantasy of something
he wants to happen and how he saw his
life going and how it's not
because she's dead yeah what if the what
if universe it was a was a warning to
the illuminati and they saw what
happened there when christine dies so
knowing that if she could die in the mcu
maybe she does die in the movie right
and that's when they show up and they're
like look buddy you're about to go
you're about
we're gonna keep you locked up here at
illuminati central i think it's
important to note that like if that's
the case which i believe is the case
there's universes in which she has died
i think it's more scary that this is a
universe where she hasn't yet so it's
like what's going on i think it's more
strange
pun intended i think it's more strange
that where our christine hasn't died yet
so that's probably i think that's more
important than anything is them noting
like if he's gonna follow suit as
everyone does in that in his nexus point
is christine dying why hasn't she died
in this timeline yet so i think that's
more of a question but i could also be
you know talking out my butt you know
i don't know i like that talking on my
butt what do you think of
what do you think of this christine
we've seen in the trailer that looks
like she's a part of the illuminati or
like sometimes every now and then when
you guys have me on shows i get stumped
oh i know crazy right i get stumped and
this is one of the ones where i'm like i
what could she be doing in there
because like if she is working for the
illuminati secretly like are they gonna
mimic sharon carter with it like how
like she's kind of been working kind of
under
this
like under everything but has been
clearly working
with shield yeah
but i don't think they would oh you
think that maybe the maybe the christine
in the mcu is like a plant from like the
illuminati she's there just yeah not the
one on everything not the one nine nine
nine one nine nine nine okay nine one
but i'm wondering if there's a universe
like kind of how rick and morty did this
where there's like a universe where rick
does die and there's either a morty or
just a beth i think that could still
work here where it's like that
that one died that doctor strange died
and so we just have christine here
that's what i was wondering jessica is
like is she from a universe where yeah
there's the car accident or whatever and
and doctor strange dies uh and this
christine is so moved by his death that
she goes on this journey and discovers
the illuminati because
she goes deep into science maybe she
doesn't learn magic but she learns she
goes just goes deep into science and
like multiverse theory and discovers
like because she's still a doctor okay
she's still a doctor and she's still
smart and so i would i would see that
more than like what if she is the doctor
strange what if christine palmer is a
doctor strange in her universe because
i'd be like she would be on the board
with the illuminati we wouldn't see her
just working adjacently so yeah i think
what your theory is is the theory that
she's in the universe where he died and
she got so into it that they just were
like hop on in jump on board get on in
sit right down we need a christine here
yes
i like your idea though jess i mean i
don't like the idea of christine dying
but i like the idea that the mcu's
christine is not long for this world and
does not make it out of multiverse of
madness alive and that'll be very
interesting i think that's when she's
gonna die so sorry so sorry christine
okay well let's talk about iron man okay
let's talk about iron man well we got we
can't save christine palmer i'm sorry in
the comics tony stark was the one who
originally brought the illuminati
together we got a tease of this when our
tony stark had an illuminati app icon on
his phone back in iron man 2. but
besides that there's been no sign that
our tony stark was involved in any
illuminati again that's what we know
that we know of he wasn't involved in it
you would think if thanos showed up he
would have called the illuminati and be
like hey guys we need a little help here
but as far as we know our
tony stark the mcu's tony stark didn't
have anything to do with the illuminati
and that app might have just been a hint
or a little
nod they were given a little easter egg
but our tony is of course dead and maybe
that's the problem should our tony stark
still be alive remember our tony is dead
because of what stephen strange told him
he told him like this is the one way to
stop thanos and now he's dead
maybe that's why
yeah
we they're like we can't work with this
universe you got rid of your tony stark
what are we supposed to do
you need him you need him we can't save
you now i i think it would be funny if
tony stark was like secretly a part of
the illuminati and then when he died
doctors they're like doctor strange
there's a list of things you've done
wrong this one is by far the worst but
like you killed one of our teammates and
you didn't even know he was a part of
our board like yeah yeah right like you
screwed things up so bad
if you had waited like a couple years we
would have come and said hello you'll be
like you guys are ready you're ready for
the illuminati but you were too soon
tony stark on his own he made quite a
mess of things right you know he nukes
the chitari he creates ultron he messes
with time travel
uh he he snaps away a time displaced
thanos right and all of his crew they
jump forward in time they have the
battle in upstate new york and he gets
rid of them so now they're gone from
that timeline like
tony stark made a mess of things whether
or not that's steven strange's fault i
don't know but he did create a lot of
problems in our universe and unlike the
comics you know like tony stark is kind
of the head of the mcu uh you know the
comics he's he's ahead of the avengers
and that's why he he kind of he creates
the illuminati there but i'm wondering
if like our tony stark kind of messed
things up so much in our universe that
along with his actions and steven
strange's actions the illuminati's like
this universe has got to go it's a mess
it's gotta go i feel like uh if just
being a mess is enough to get the world
reset then we definitely should but i do
think there's people on the people on
the board of the illuminati there are
still like bad guys like namor is not
is not good or bad yeah he puts atlantis
first that's for sure that's always
putting atlantis first yeah everybody
comes from different viewpoints
everybody comes to different backgrounds
and that needs to be made at that table
so everyone can have a say so i think
tony being bad or doing bad stuff
doesn't isn't negatively impacting the
illuminati they're like yeah it's fine
you did blow up a lot of countries but i
guess that's fine he didn't run i think
i think it's the messing with time all
those people he snapped away with thanos
all those bad guys who came to fight
with thanos i mean some of those guys
might have just been there they're like
look this is the only job i could get in
the universe i got a family back at home
you know i'm paying bills i got a
mortgage you know my planet's interest
rate is out of control i'm just doing my
job i didn't know we were coming to
earth i didn't know we're going to jump
through time i was just on the ship i
didn't know we're going to jump through
time whoa what the [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa
what what
they're not all bad that's what i'm
gonna say i'm sure their family was like
threatened to come every strongest
person in every house and they're like
damn that's me
it's the old argument with the the
stormtroopers on the death star right
not all of them are bad guys okay some
of them are just working some of them
were conscripted they were pulled out of
their land and put shoved into a little
uh a stormtrooper suit and put on the
death star and then kablooey they get
blown up by some farmer who's got a bad
attitude from tatooine okay that's
i think tony you know he was he was an
arrogant guy i mean that's the point of
the illuminati right each of them
represents a powerful force in the world
and they're always looking out for their
people first their people come first but
they're trying to they're trying to work
together the best they can
our tony stark you know he created a lot
of problems and now he's gone that might
be why they want to delete us
a little bit just a little bit not as
much as
what dr strange has done and
not as much as technically christine
palmer has done but it sucks because
christine palmer didn't do anything
wrong it's by because she'd do anything
wrong except live all she had to do was
breathe and for some reason the entire
universe is being flipped upside down
because this guy can't calm down maybe
go to a hospital on the the west coast
next time christine don't go to new york
don't get messed up with stephen's have
you heard of cedar cyanide have you
heard of kaiser permanente go beyond
grey's anatomy don't be hanging out in
new york okay come on what are you doing
here you can have 25 seasons on grey's
anatomy you'll live forever let's talk
about someone who is actually a villain
sometimes all the time it depends on how
you view them the god of mischief baby
loki he's caused a lot of mayhem in the
mcu and loki and sylvie are partially
responsible for creating the chaos
that's going on in multiverse i mean we
don't know if it's all them it's
probably all the things that are
happening all at once but there's no
doubt that loki and sylvie played a role
oh uh yeah is the fact that our kang aka
he who remains was killed a problem
worthy of destroying our universe should
they have let him live okay think about
it
yes they show up and he who remains his
room and he's like look you can kill me
and you're gonna let the chaos in or you
let me keep doing my thing you keep
doing what i'm doing you play by the
book do you play by the script and
everything will be okay now loki didn't
stab him it was silly but sophie is a
loki they're kind of the same so
plus who has this loki's done a bunch of
other things loki's caused a lot of
other problems in our multiverse do you
think that the illuminati is showing up
being like you guys killed the kang that
was holding all the other kings back and
we needed that kang we needed he who
remains to be alive in your universe
keeping your timelines together running
in one direction and now that he's gone
it's created too much chaos and we can't
let our universe be destroyed wherever
the illuminati's from they're like we
can't let our universe be destroyed we
got to stop yours it's out of control
i feel like it's so it's such child
behavior to be like but it wasn't like
us it was kang kang was the bad guy and
it's like yeah but the bad guy was
behind bars until you let him
in free sylvia yeah you had a choice you
had a choice it all to you he was like
it's got to go this way absolutely you
got to let these rules stay in place
that is absolutely going to be on the
list of reasons why it needs to be
they're going to be like you open
pandora's box like you you just let
everything go if that man survived we
wouldn't have had this problem honestly
he was doing them kind of a favor by
becoming the time keepers like he was
doing the illuminati a huge face he was
keeping or it wasn't good he wasn't good
no i don't stand with him
look i don't
say that i i didn't say i stand with how
he did it but
he was doing something and again the
illuminati is not all right all the time
but from their perspective if like our
kang being killed and causing all this
chaos is not good for their universe
they're gonna step in and be like look
you guys gotta go you guys are you guys
have gotta go okay you guys gotta get
out it's very much like the matrix right
jessica all you know six or seven neos
before the neo we knew was like nope
this is cool reset it baby let's go
let's keep it going i'm solid and then
our neo shows up and it's like no i'm
not playing that game anymore i'm in
love with trinity anyways this is not
about the matrix trinity and crystal
it's a very similar situation it's
always love
don't fall for it don't fall for love
it's a trap it's a trap it's a trap
let's talk about our our genetic friends
with the x gene okay the mcu as far as
we know as far as we know does not have
any mutants or at least the plethora of
mutants as we know them in the comics on
one division they teased that wanda and
pietro were possibly already mutants but
where are all the mutants okay where are
the mutants in the mcu are they just in
hiding how how could they be hiding for
this long is the fact that the mcu
doesn't have mutants a problem is that
why we're marked for deletion
[Music]
no
no no presumably we don't have a
professor x right we don't we don't have
a gene gray controlling the phoenix
force all these things could just be
going
chaotic in our universe but then it's
like
we do have a wanda
and that
is chaotic enough does that mean i'm
like yeah so i guess it depends on what
we're gonna do
if we're gonna give wanda and monica
that like mutant if we're gonna call
them mutants
um then it's like are these people
helping or making the earth worse uh and
it's like scarlet witch kind of is
monica
m.i.a
and
i don't know if the illuminati would
look at uh her being like off-planet as
being destructive to our current earth
but she's not doing any good right now
she's not doing bad and she's not doing
it do you think it's possible that our
our mutants are gone or don't exist
because we we have like a no more
mutants moment but from like a a
different universe like somehow they
knew our universe was trouble and
they're like don't give that universe
mutants i'm the scarlet witch from a
different universe and i looked in on
them and i'm like no no no no
no
they tested it they were like if wanted
as well here we'll see about it then
they're like oh no no no no no it's not
gonna work out no no this is a bad idea
so i've been reading weird theories
about like the x-men there's so many
theories about like why we haven't seen
the x-men in the mcu and it's more so
now becoming a situation of like
giving the marvel company like ideas on
how to bring the mutants into the mcu
and i like the idea and this is kind of
a good getaway of the no mutants thing
happened already
and no one's aware of it yet
and so maybe that situation can happen
where it was like the moons were wiped
ages ago uh but in the other universes
they exist
it's i just don't think it's a reason
for a deletion
if they don't exist if that makes sense
it's just it's weird the mutants are
makes sense
yeah the mutants are weird well while
we're talking about let's let's also
talk about the scarlet witch okay
because yeah we don't have mutants right
now and maybe that's a good thing maybe
that's a problem maybe the scarlet witch
did it before she when she was younger
and she didn't even know like in her
mind seeing all that war and stuff and
seeing the power of people she was like
in her mind she was like
i don't want anyone to be too powerful
in this world and like wiped out the
mutants as a child or something like
that i don't know maybe maybe not i i
don't know i don't know i like children
with too much power
well let's talk about the scholar witch
okay she's a nexus being in the comics
uh and they've teased just as much as in
the mcu you know they had that word
commercial with like nexus and stuff
like that she's a nexus being she might
be the most powerful wielder of magic in
in the mcu universe right that's kind of
what the dark holders said more powerful
than sorcerer supreme is are scarlet
witch a problem and is she already
creating havoc across the multiverse is
that what she's been doing at her little
cabin and the illuminati is going to
show up and tell dr strange like here's
the truth we got to destroy your
universe cause your scarlet witch is too
strong
she's got to go yes and no
yes and no because i'm thinking about it
and i'm like well okay so
what what has what has she done so she
imprisoned the minds of people in new
jersey she uh ripped up uh sokovia she
brought it brought it into the air threw
it back down um technically there was
that that was that was mostly ultron
that was mostly that was mostly ultron
but they think but they think it's her
the uh the like oh well i guess the
illuminati might not assume it's her but
everyone else thinks it's her and same
with the altercation they had
with the building catching fire
the reason why she got put on my house
arrest in the first place
so
it's like are those
big enough for the illuminati to
recognize as a huge problem those are
big enough those aren't the big problems
maybe the west view thing is a warning
and it's a warning this is dangerous but
she hasn't done anything else well i
think maybe our scarlet witch is like
too powerful and not educated enough on
on wielding that power like she's
learning she's learning as fast as she
can with the dark hole but i think the
fact that she learned about her kids
from another dimension too early without
understanding her power
it's made her too dangerous and now the
uh uh the alumni is gonna show up
they're like she's too powerful we gotta
we gotta delete this universe and dr
strange's gonna be like whoa you can't
do that come on and they're like dr
strange you wanna kill people all the
time what are you talking about yeah
what's up i've changed i don't wanna do
it anymore well that's the thing is i
don't think they have like
and maybe this is me playing devil's
advocate i they don't have the evidence
that she has made it as bad as
dr strange has because she's messed with
time but she's not
erasing the minds of everyone on the
planet like she's not opening a gate for
all of these like villains to come
through but i also think they're way
worse the other the wanda that we're
seeing in the trailer for the multiverse
of madness is not the same wanda as what
we have on our planet so if that wanda
got out this is another one yeah i think
that's a different one and if that wanda
got out into our dimension then that's a
problem the legends or in ours as in
earth
that's a 1999
so that's where i'm like that's why i
say yes or no because i'm like if that
wanda jumps out into the earth one nine
nine nine nine nine yay
the illuminati can easily be like we
need to reset while she's on that earth
like she's she's coming we need to get
rid of her while she's on that planet i
like that that makes sense that makes
sense well here's one for you jessica
and this one this is my biggest stretch
this is a big stretch for you but i
think it could be important okay maybe
the illuminati's beef with our dimension
our universe has nothing to do with
doctor strange and has everything to do
with the celestials and the eternals in
the mcu okay yeah for as we saw in the
internals film they were able to stop
the birth of tiamat perhaps the
illuminati were counting on this
happening in order to wipe out the earth
which causes so much problem in the
multiverse and the fact that they
stopped it they're gonna show up and be
like sorry guys you gotta go
you were supposed to die and now once
again you haven't died and so we gotta
wipe you out and all these characters
that we know and love like professor x
and maybe a tony stark maybe a black
panther who knows who's on the
illuminati in the mcu
maybe they're gonna be like sorry you
guys gotta go you gotta die your
teammate you stopped your tmi you got to
die
the eternals also are just like
a mess our eternals are a mess yeah they
are our journals are messed up
and they mess with time a lot like not
only are they like doing it currently
but just over time their boss is dead
they're they're going off to fight
aeroshem yeah i think they're a little
worried about our eternals just running
loose and being crazy i can i can see
that and i understand that and i um
that that one i'm like yeah you can go
ahead i guess go ahead with it they
they made things kind of worse okay
here's one more little one i don't even
have this one in the script but i meant
to put this one in there here's one more
little one jessica
could it be because our universe no
longer has infinity stones
that it's got to go i had that in my
maybe pile trust yourself jake thanos
claims to have snapped him away he
claims that i don't i don't think it's
true you calling me a liar i ain't
calling you a truther he claims to have
snapped him away the russo brothers
confirmed that they were atomized their
essence still exists in our universe but
the stones physically are gone do you
think because those stones were
destroyed the alumni is gonna show up
and be like you gotta go you don't have
your stones anymore you you're you're a
hot mess you're ticking time bomb
because in the comics one thing the
illuminati does is they they get all six
of the stones and they split them up
between them and that way that they're
all safe which is not the safest way to
deal with that but they they keep them
all safe you think because we lost our
infinity stones they've been atomized
that the illuminati is like look you
guys are too dangerous you don't have
the most powerful thing in your universe
anymore you we can't we got to get rid
of you you're you're you're you're just
too much of a wild card i agree with you
but then i'm also like it just seems too
easy when we just saw loki and they're
using it as paperweights to just re-hand
them out i like especially people you'll
show up and be like hey look i brought
some i got the anthony stone we got him
we're cool
can uh i always call him by eugene
cordero is who plays that character in
the loki series and i'm always like hey
eugene bring us some more paperweights
and it's just a bunch of the stones so
that's why if i never saw that scene in
loki i would have been like oh the
stones are still very valuable and very
like hard like very important but now
that i saw it like that i was like so
you can just hand these out so they
could be like gifts like anyone can get
a stone in
in the time zone time zone in the time
you pick up time
if you pick them from some pluck
timelines yeah sure yeah well that seems
like if you just want it it just makes
it seem like they're they are important
i i recognize they are but with the the
illuminati i think they'd be like you
lost your stones that just that's
another thing on their list of like you
guys are a mess you lost your stones
dude like who does that no one loses
their stones who does that
come on guys keep track of your stones
okay jessica taking all of these things
into consideration and all the other
crimes our universe has committed do you
think that the illuminati are going to
try and take out earth
i 199-999 love for that to be the case
and i could see doctor strange being too
attached to clearly the people that are
on that planet christine cough cough
um christine kofkoff and him trying so
hard to save it and then by the end of
the movie them being like let's not do
it but namor is like
i'm mad at them we should have destroyed
them when we had the chance do it do it
flood them
flood the earth
do
i it love to see it happen will it
happen not sure but i would love to see
them take out okay well i think it's i
think that's definitely what the
illuminati are here to do they're gonna
take it out the truth they're gonna tell
dr strange is like uh we're gonna wipe
out your dimension so sorry you can hang
out here at headquarters with us and
grab a bunk somewhere but the rest of
everyone's gonna go and our doctor
strange is gonna be like oh hell no
because he's bad he's evil he's a badass
dude he's gonna be like i'm gonna kill
the illuminati baby and he's going to
kill those illuminati that's what's
going to happen book it ship it it's
happening he's going to
if i finally get one little piece of
x-men and then dr strange kills it it
just kills me i'll lose my [ __ ] i will
stop it's going to be the biggest swerve
the biggest swerve in the end i'll be so
i'll walk out the theater and then walk
right back in
doctor straight is going to use his
injured hands to choke the life out of
professor is his fingers all backwards
he's like come over here
[Laughter]
there you go oh my god well i i can't
wait to read every get all the tweets
that are like save our planet and i'm
gonna be like destroy the planet but
but i just want to add our little merch
plug so there are some really cool new
moon night hoodies for sale over at the
epic hero shop.com this is not one of
them this is i keep grabbing my shirt
this is not one of them i'm not wearing
it right now this is just a dare shirt
there are black and white hoodies
inspired by different personas of moon
knight keep an eye out at epic hero shop
for other cool moon night products
dropping soon and before we dive into
our bite size questions next some words
from the people that help bring big
question to you our friends at avast are
a global leader in cyber security for
more than 30 years they've been keeping
folks safe and they're trusted by over
435 million users avast empowers you
with digital safety and privacy no
matter who you are where you are or how
you connect enjoy the opportunities that
come with being connected on your terms
thanks to avast for supporting big
question a vast new all-in-one solution
avast one helps you take control of your
safety and privacy online through a
range of features learn more about avast
one at avast.com we like that a vast one
is like one stop shop for taking care of
all the bad things that can happen to
your computer or online presence viruses
malware data breaches a vast one has
great tools to monitor for and prevent
all of that awful stuff they're like the
kind and very smart uncle keeping an eye
out for you and your computer they even
have great ransomware protection that
keeps your personal photos documents and
other files from being changed or
deleted avast prevents over 1.5 billion
attacks every month and with a vast one
you can confidently take control of your
online world without worrying about
viruses phishing attacks ransomware
hacking attempts and other cyber crime
learn more about a vast one at avast.com
that's avast.com
avast.com this time of year when the
weather is wildly different from day to
day you're never sure how to dress
luckily faraday makes it way easier they
make the perfect clothes for all seasons
verity is a family run brand making high
quality timeless clothing that has great
modern design and awesome functionality
what we love about faraday clothes is
how high quality they are while still
looking great i always feel like a
slightly cooler person when i'm wearing
faraday shirts and sweaters don't tell
anyone i'm not actually cool as i appear
uh i'm pretty lame
their clothes also just have the feeling
of super high quality in a world of fast
fashion that dissolves after wearing it
twice farady stands out these threads
are made to last and verdi's so
confident in the quality of their stuff
they have a lifetime guarantee of
quality they'll replace or fix your
clothes forever no matter what talk
about making it easier to get dressed
and right now faraday is giving all big
question listeners 20 off 20 percent off
head to faritybrand.com and use code
bigquestion at checkout to snag 20 off
all your new spring samples that's code
big question at faraday f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand.com for 20 off all right and now
for our bite size questions
everybody knows i'm hungry
who are first funny because i'm thirsty
so
anyways
anyways
brandon is spider-man's webbing affected
by temperature or moisture says
on discord and also perfect name great
name this was a great question because i
never really thought about this um
and while real spider webs are affected
by atmospheric conditions we must
remember that peter parker was smart
enough to develop his own synthetic
webbing with a little more durability
but is this special webbing that he has
made affected by atmospheric conditions
i don't think so
while spider-man's webs in the mcu are
designed to dissolve after two hours
that's what he told childish gambino aka
prowler and spider-man homecoming no no
no no
come fix this they're built to handle
whatever the weather may be like that
day in the comics it says they dissolve
after an hour but same difference right
but i can't seem to find any instance of
the humidity like ruining the webbing
and i think because his webs are so
synthetic uh like they're made of all
these special materials
they're not going to get ruined by like
a a really sunny day drying out the web
or something like that like they're
pretty they're pretty durable
i think so he's safe in any weather he's
safe than anyone i think the only
weather that will actually be
detrimental is just like a hurricane
like hurricane super super storm sandy
what are you gonna do in that was gonna
swing from ice yeah i mean that might
blow his web out of the way like the
wind might be too strong
so yeah maybe that's the way you beat
spider-man you got to put him in like a
wind tunnel so that way oh my god storm
storm versus spider-man oh
spider-man would be pretty good have no
chance spider-man would have that's the
part he wouldn't have a chance he
wouldn't get a chance to actually get a
hit on hey you know what happens to a
spider who's struck by lightning what
the same thing that happens to everybody
else
yeah when i was an old man already you
were never an old man i was born an old
man you're born in dog years do you know
what happens to a toad when it struck by
lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else
give me the second question give me the
second bite okay i'm gonna give you a
question now jessica are you ready how
old is chewbacca in the original trilogy
and what is the average lifespan of a
wookie um old enough to party you get
it's from super bad the movie that came
out in 2009
i was too old to see it oh my god
whatever i told you mclovin old enough
old enough for what
it's a party
everyone loves a wookie until they rip
your arms off but just how old is our
favorite wookie chewbacca after he made
his first chronological appearance in
revenge of the sith during battle of
kashyyyk it was during his next
appearance on the film timeline that we
would learn his age in solo a star wars
story chewbacca lets han know that he's
190 years old
190 years old
you look great
he's like i'm 190. it's like cool story
and you're still jumping and running
jumping and running like a sprite 21
year old so surprised so surprised so
surprised so limber now now now you may
think that's old but wookie's average
lifespan is over 400 standard years they
are turtles they are turtles and i've
said it before and i'm saying it again
so when a new hope kicks off he's about
200 years old and then about 235 years
old by the events of rise of the
skywalker that means all the events of
the star wars films are basically one
big midlife crisis for our boy chewbacca
that's pretty funny
if he's like halfway through growing up
he's like i'm gonna go i'm gonna go sail
around the galaxy with a human
uh or carillion or whatever han is and
and you know just do my thing and then i
find myself home
yeah i just gotta find myself okay you
don't understand i don't know who i am
yet i don't know who i am do you think
he dyed his hair like that's not even
his natural hair color he's hair
uh he bleached the tips for sure and
then they just he just let his roots
grow out he found he found his look yeah
he found his look like chewbacca was
like working in an office you know he's
working for an insurance company on
kashi apparently didn't put one of the
new cover sheets on your tps reports
he's like screw this i'm gonna go fight
yeah one day he turned his chair around
back smuggler now sat in inside what am
i doing here
what am i what am i doing with my what
am i saying he's like honey please you
can't don't leave on a diet on life day
you can't leave us now i got to go babe
i'm sorry i'm going after cigarettes i
might never come back we'll go be a
smuggler and travel the stars i love the
difference in like the that what we
normally see is like i'm going out for a
pack of cigarettes they never come back
he warned her he warned her this stuff
and said i'm going out and said i'm not
coming back
you better move on babe
i'm out of here
like you remember when you were 145 you
looked great now you're 190 you're
terrible 190. what the hell is going on
girl what's going on babe oh god and now
i hate you
everybody
are we ready for the box of scraps
oh the box of scraps
[Music]
can we play the tone of him yelling box
of scraps from iron man stew we used to
i don't think we've done in a while but
for you jessica we're gonna do it right
now hit it box of scraps
i love it i'm here for it i hope they
did it it's also kind of attractive
[Music]
just a guy here's our box of scraps for
today what is the most harmless thing
you think that a secret cabal controls
in our world okay
imagine we have our
oh well imagine we have our own secret
illuminati it doesn't exist but if it
did exist what what what is the most
harmless thing that they control in our
world
they control the met gal oh you think
that's like the illuminati like the real
illuminati does
you hear this met gala fans
i want them to control the met gala you
think they do it to like make
celebrities dress up weird just as like
a weird power play or something like
that i think having yes i think it's
just to make fun of celebrities no i
think if we want to get weird i think it
would be they would get like because you
know how people the fans are so obsessed
with the looks and this and that and
doing everything once they get in the
building nothing happens
nothing's going on inside it's just to
get our attention i feel like i'm
getting into a weird conspiracy theory
that might actually be true i like that
but that okay so if i don't want to be
weird about it i think a weird thing
they would control are like celebrity
baby photos because uh what do we love
most next to the met gala uh celebrity
baby celebrity babies
celebrities they're all fake
yeah they're not real they're just like
cake
you know how that trend like it's a real
or it's a cake it's just a cake it's
just a baby cake and then they eat it
after the photo's done here's what i
think jessica i think there's a secret
cabal out there that makes sure that
every
candy that is supposed to taste like
watermelon doesn't actually taste like
watermelon what is that artificial
watermelon flavor it's insane it's so
good that it doesn't matter it's so good
no but that's not what watermelon tastes
the watermelon sour patch is the best
thing that has ever been given to me and
i don't care that it doesn't taste like
water that's that's what all watermelon
tastes like watermelon with our brains
they're programming us you should be mad
about the banana artificial flavor
because that's not banana but watermelon
eats the banana no one eats the bananas
the banana nerds the banana
you're out of your mind everyone loves
the watermelon and it doesn't taste like
watermelon and they're messing with our
brains that's it okay go ahead i'm
falling for it put that
strap me up throw it in my veins
i will take that artificial watermelon
flavor until the day i die i love it do
it it's probably just like a lot of corn
syrup and like goat hoof but i'm still
full
i'm still falling for it i love it it's
delicious i can't believe there's
i get that there's people that don't
like it i get those people that don't
like it but i think both of our theories
for the box of scraps could be true
i think they are true i think they are
going to get eliminated because you've
been spreading the truth the illuminati
the they are definitely doctor strange
is going to kill me doctor strange is
the people you don't see me
if you don't see me next week i've been
taken out by the illuminati okay okay or
me one or the other oh i'm a part of the
illuminati all right all right okay you
guys that was his episode of big
question every conspiracy theory you've
ever had about the mcu or in reality has
just been served to you on a plate by me
and brandon uh i want to thank brandon
off-screen producer uh brandon for
joining us today on this episode follow
him at grin and barrack on twitter and
other platforms follow me at lulu
underscore clemens follow at new
rockstars here on youtube and all social
media platforms and make sure to hit
that notification bell like subscribe
comment and if you want to continue this
conversation on our new rockstars
discord you can do that it's now open to
the public and all you have to do is be
over the ages of 18 and also interested
in our content
so click the link for the new rockstars
discord in the server description and
below and i i guess that's it after this
discussion i feel kind of weird i feel
like some there's going to be like a dot
on my head from my window and i'm gonna
get shot i'm afraid
i'm very afraid jessica i'm very afraid
we're all gonna die
bye
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]